afin de favoriser l'accès aux soins de
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus le
conseil départemental de la Réunion a
initié depuis 2007 le chèque santé le
chèque santé permet aux personnes âgées
aux revenus modestes d'acquérir une
couverture maladie via une
complémentaire santé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous mettons en lumière le
dispositif chaque santé cette aide
financière du département a été mise en
place pour permettre aux personnes âgées
aux revenus modestes de payer le reste à
charge mensuel qui leur incombe auprès
d'une mutuelle affilié allô alors
rencontre de Marielle qui a bénéficié de
ce dispositif
[Musique]
sur le compte là
sur la pointe on les prélèvement
vous avez besoin de s'inquiète pas parce
que le chèque santé avec déduit dessus
j'accentais directement payé à la
mutuelle et la mutuelle après il déduit
son montant chaque santé
voilà c'est ça d'accord et après les
démarches n'a pas été très compliqué à
faire mais avant ne pas être difficile
mais une fois à la demande c'est à
demander les documents c'est les
documents qu'il faut bien le problème
est là une fois la fois nuit mais elle
est pas
trop difficile ça va 15 jours ou 15
jours ou 15 ou 17
la réponse merci Marielle mais merci
maronie
[Musique]
le dispositif chaque santé s'adresse aux
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus
résident à la Réunion et une bénéficions
pas de complémentaires santé solidaire
le chèque santé délivrer ce
justification de droit ouvert à la CSS
avec participation financière de la CGSS
ou se justificatif de recevoir et
s'élève à une hauteur de 30 euros
maximum par mois et par personne
[Musique]
bonjour Huguette
Huguette comment fonctionne le Jacques
santé et qui peut en bénéficier alors
pour un bénéficier la personne âgée doit
justifier d'une attestation de
complémentaires santé solidaire avec
participation ou sinon de justificatif
de ressources à savoir pour une personne
seule des ressources qui sont entre une
fourchette de 889 euros à 1198 euros
donc ensuite quels sont les démarches la
personne doit se rapprocher du service
aide social aux adultes donc il y en a
quatre à la Réunion 4 antennes une sur
Saint-Pierre une apathe au caillot une
sur Saint-Denis et une dans l'Est le
service ASA instruit la demande de
chaque santé transmet ensuite à la
personne elle reçoit donc à son domicile
par la poste une lettre chèque que
celle-ci peut faire valoir ensuite à sa
mutuelle et qui est déduite justement de
sa contribution à la complémentaire
santé merci beaucoup Huguette merci
Maroni très bonne journée
grâce à ce dispositif mis en place
depuis 2007 cette année plus de 29000
personnes ont pu bénéficier du chèque
santé cette aide financière du
département permet à nos grands mondes
plus serein concernant leur frais
relatifs à la santé
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur les dispositifs
chaque santé n'hésitez pas vous avez
toutes les coordonnées qui s'affichent
en bas de votre écran le département des
générations c'est fini si vous voulez
revoir cet épisode ainsi que les
épisodes précédents rendez-vous sur
notre site et mes réseaux sociaux quant
à moi je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]